vor einem jahr im urlaub habe ich mir
mal eine barbie zeitschrift gekauft und
in einem video auf den doktor sommer
teil reagiert und das lustigste an der
ganzen zeitschrift waren diese komischen
love stories also wo leute
beispielsweise so stehen oder dessen
text erleben so was theoretisch sagen
würden und jetzt war ich mal ein
bisschen im internet unterwegs und hab
mir die chronisten crash love stories
rausgesucht die es gibt
wir starten direkt mit dieser hier das
mittelinks sagt hey thomas wie geht das
sagt thomas alles bleiben und bei der
nächsten love story geht es um zwei
mädels und zwar ist das eine medium
verliebt in einen jungen namens länder
und das andere ist die beste freude und
versucht ihr quasi mut auszusprechen
von wegen hey du schon so ihr kommen
safe zusammen daher sagt die beste
freundin hier links werden dann erstmal
kapiert hat die charmant und siehst du
bist dann punkt um punkt und dann bricht
ihre beste freundin die auf lenz steht
in das gespräch ein und sagt sorry aber
ich glaube da kündigt sich gerade ein
kleiner bub schatten
[Musik]
wenn dann nicht unter sich denn das hier
ist die nächste szene sagt die person in
der mitte also ländern gaben dazu sagen
hey amelie bord krass versteckt denn
hier so richtig wie ein gewalt
[Musik]
alle lieben und sterben und die rechte
bässe und diverse freude sagt das glaube
ich jetzt nicht so viel berlin an einem
tag sein das war amelie fried ich
wünschte ich wäre früher auf bravo
zeitschrift gekommen er meine kindheit
werde so viel witziger gewesen bei der
nächsten lovestory unterhalten sich ein
junge und ein mädchen über eine aktion
die das mädchen gebracht hat und der
junge also der beste freund von dem
mädel will sie daraufhin aufmuntern und
sagt nein schon fies dass du lehrer in
den keller gesperrt hast aber irgendwie
auch bei der nächsten lovestory geht es
um tim und niklas und zwar sind dass
diese beiden personen der team sagt hey
mädels genau also brust raus bauch rein
und lächeln und daraufhin sagt niklas
was geht ab jetzt alles normal im
liveticker
ihr könnt mir doch nicht sagen falls
irgendjemand gerade zuschauer der
vielleicht schon irgendwie über 30 ist
oder so um den dreh weil diese bravourös
auf die ich hier die ich mir heraus und
habe das alles schon ein bisschen älter
ihr könnt mir doch nicht sagen dass man
früher einen raum rein kamen und weiter
alles denn bei euch das geo special
alles normal im live auf jeden fall
danach auch einfach noch ohne dass
irgendein anderer daneben steht aber
unser swag reicht für 1000
ja ich könnte vor gericht im erdboden
versinken
und dann gibt es noch in hier er sagt
einfach ich habe überhaupt keinen zweck
heute ja das ist halt blöd solche tage
gibt es mein lieber bei der nächsten
love story geht es um max und sabine und
zwar will der max ein bisschen mit ihr
flirten und so ein gespräch anfangen
also zumindest erstmal diesen ersten
schritt gehen und das eis brechen um so
ein bisschen ja gespräche überhaupt zu
kommen und max fragt daraufhin kannst du
reiten sitzt auf seinem fahrrad rechts
daneben sehen wir jetzt sabine die sagt
nee ich will auch nicht reiten ja aber
jetzt folgenden love story geht es um
sven und lolita und zwar ist das lolita
übernahme naja lolita ist auf jeden fall
ein bisschen schlecht gelaunt und sven
versucht sie aufzumuntern und sagt hier
nimm einen lolli für lolli das gibt
nervenkraft danke sven aber da hilft
auch kein lolli mehr
ein lolli für lolita es wenn wir hatten
die erzieherin geschlossen die nächste
love story handelt von zwei jungs und
zwar steht der eine junge auf einem
mädchen und der andere junge ärgert
dieses mädchen und der junge das mädchen
steht will das mädchen dementsprechend
beschützen sagt lasst sie in ruhe ab und
der andere junge sagte dummerweise junge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich ich ich ich sprachen lernen da die
nächste love story handelt von einer
party auf der der liebe jonas zu
besuchen der streit darum hyper hyper
techno scooter kussi und dann gibt es
draußen allerdings noch die coolen kids
die dann so meinte le paris nicht cool
genug für uns oder hey freundlich
formuliert wir möchten einfach gehen wir
müssen nach hause unsere eltern sagen
wir so nach hause kommen derjenige der
hier allerdings kein bock auf die party
hat sagt einfach diese party ist ja
genauso langweilig wie lena ist schon
immer war ihr habt doch null plan wie
man richtig abfeiern mit seiner richtig
geilen spacigen brille die ja darauf hat
ja
nicht das nächste mal vor der party nach
hause sei es genauso langweilig leder
das immer weiter
aber wenn ich ankomme frage ich erstmal
bandes bei euch ist was geht ab im
splash
das heißt du das ding was ich mich oft
frage werde ich später vor meine kinder
wenn ich dann meinen kumpels hallo sage
hey was geht die hier alles klar wenn
ihnen auch sagen wo er sagt so was wir
sagen alles und noch mehr aber wisst ihr
was ich meine ich glaube das ist dann
generationen ding einfach und wenn ich
mir jetzt auch sage hey ich will später
so der coolste vater überhaupt sei
einfach meinen kindern
dann werde ich trotzdem wahrscheinlich
ziemlich uncool sein weil die andere
sachen dann einfach cool finden machen
allerdings jetzt weiter mit dieser
person die richtig gut flirten kann und
zwar sagt dem studio wie du bist meine
nudeln und ich das ketchup dazu ist
alles in ordnung
die anderen ja die gab also flirten
kannst du auf jeden fall nächste love
story handelt von einem verliebten
pärchen und vielleicht kennt ihr das
wenn man frisch verliebt ist dass man
irgendwie alles auf einmal cool findet
was der andere sagt und alles irgendwie
feiert und der andere person bei allem
zustimmt so deine freundin oder deinen
freunden kann ankommen und sagen boah
ich liebe ja es spinat mit grünkohl und
rotkohlsaft zum früh schon gesagt wow
das auch mein absolutes lieblingsessen
essig tag und nacht hier sagt auf jeden
fall das mädel das sind gar keine lamas
das sind alpakas und dann sagt die
andere juhu ich freue mich wenn du mir
den unterschied erklärst dk sie hat mir
gesagt dass du falsch liegst um das dass
lamas und alpakas sind also beruhigt
deine basis und komm wieder rein display
scheint ein normales live die erste love
story handelt von einem jungen und ein
mädchen und ich würde sagen ich zeig
euch einfach direkt das mädel sache
nämlich ehrlich gesagt suche ich einen
jungen firma ein erstes mal daraufhin
erwidert der junge da bist du bei mir
genau an der richtigen adresse ich bin
nämlich der nato
[Musik]
ja
er kenne die nicht mehr bei der nächsten
lovestory wollen heidel traut und
annette mal so richtig das tanzbein
schwingen und heidel trotz sagt dass wir
da heute abend der hit aus vier mach ich
eine richtige rave queen
daraufhin sagt annette ja heute bogen
wir bis der acker wackelt
ja ich hoffe ja heute auch genug speck
dabei den nächsten love story will eine
junge so richtig krones zeigen und sagen
wer hier der boss im revier ist und sagt
ihm entsprechend dieser stadtteil gehört
mir wäre damit ein problem hat bekommt
was auf die fresse jamin jungen dir
gehört bestimmt der komplette stadtteil
der nächsten situation geht es um einen
jungen der gerade aufgewacht ist und an
seinem körper runter schaut und sagt na
mein großer bist du wieder vor mir
aufgewacht kein wunder die ganzen mädels
ging mir nicht aus dem kopf mein gott
wer
wenn ich das früher gelesen hätte alter
ich werde direkt auf toilette gerade 24
tage lang gekotzt betrachtet sich im
spiegel und denkt sich war wie gern
hätte ich auch mal so ein scharfes teil
yanar das denke ich mir auch jedes mal
wenn ich mir auch so und bei der
nächsten love story geht es um ein
pärchen und zwar ein junge und ein
mädchen und das mädchen möchte in ein
auto einsteigen kommt allerdings nicht
so richtig rein und daraufhin hat der
junge mehrfach auf den arsch sagt loos
rhein mit dir baby girl und das mädel
stucky
ich mag jetzt wenn du mir auf dem buch
[Musik]
kommen allerdings auch schon zur
vorletzten lauf solche für heute und
zwar geht es um einen mann dem ein
restaurant gehört und der flirtet ein
bisschen mit seiner kellnerin und er
sagt dein outfit heute ist nicht nur
raten sondern echtem scharf da wird ja
jeder echte kerl schwach tricksen doch
etwas drunter ich hoffe nicht naja warum
finden sie das nicht selbst aus
ich kann mir das nicht mehr geben ich
mein das ding ist halt auch der letzte
lovestory fail wird sicherlich schon
standard bei so viel weil ich vollauf zu
ebay fels hochladen aber ob er jeden
fall geht es bei der letzten love story
um einen jungen und ein mädchen die
erstes mal haben und die reden da
irgendwie nicht so normal drüber sondern
die sitzen einfach halbnackt im bett und
der junge sagt first time in das konto
nicht gar nicht mehr das ist so lustig
absolut ja und irgendwie gewöhnt man
sich so an den umgang mit den comic ist
[Musik]
wie können wir doch nicht sagen dass das
das so ich meine soll er irgendwie nah
an der realität seien diese lovestory
den leuten auch was mitbringen und ich
meine das ist ja auch ganz cool und ganz
süß und keine ahnung was los ist so
blind so recht und fassbar team versagt
das mädel dann ich glaube flow will dass
ich mir keinen kopf machen wegen des
ersten mals richtig süß von ihm jahr
flog allerdings weiter und sie reiben
das kondom über die haare und das mädel
sagt die teile halten ja ganz gut was
aus da fühlt man sich gleich sicherer ja
so ein kondom kann ordentlich was
einstecken
du bist mein kind hält er das ist ja
wahnsinn kommen wir nun allerdings auch
zum letzten will dieser fünfteiligen
love story reihe hier am ende und zwar
ist das hier nicht dass wir alle
aufbrachen ohne es getan zu haben
es sind noch drei da das dürfte für den
anfang wohl reich
[Musik]
der m